[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
it is the final four we are all in Las
Vegas but I I I see Logan got a t-shirt
parlay going on but Bryson what is that
that you're wearing
well it's my own Roberts hoodie man we I
gave out first half money line two weeks
ago in this exact same spot they should
have hit man
I don't want to hear Oral Roberts come
out of your mouth ever again it's been
14 days since that moment I watched you
walk out of the casino
I watched you walk out
it's been two weeks Bryson Logan they
play the game a hundred times they play
a hundred times we win that bet more
times than we lose bro
that's all I have to say that's all I
have to say hey let's move let's move on
Bryson's stuck in the past but I'm
trying to be stuck winning money in the
future uh welcome everybody welcome to
the show my name is Greg Ivory next to
me you guys see his name is Bryson
Stricker we like to call I like to call
it B money you know what I'm saying
because he likes to cash in those bets
and next to him to the far right we have
Mr Bagel in life Mr t-shirt the T-shirt
parlay or you could just simply call
them Logan what up boys uh let's go
let's get straight to it let's get
straight to it we are cooking up today
what do we need from the audience Bryson
foreign
we need winners first off everybody send
us stuff but dude we gotta talk about
something here man real quick assuming
we're in the right Spire dude first of
ten is what everybody's betting in this
tournament who cares about anything else
who cares who wins the game I can't tell
you I can't see the future but what I
can tell you is we're going to have a
really really good time putting together
our first attempt parlay today Logan
Greg I don't know if you guys have takes
man but I'm leading FAU UConn that's
just where my head's at I don't know if
the chat has other opinions but that's
where my head's at
yeah I do like the FAU the FAU lean
there they start hot uh we talked about
it before the show
they're either making it rain from Deep
or they're chucking up threes right and
that that will determine the outcome of
this bet the beauty of the first to ten
in the first half especially is you know
if you need to chase you know if you're
bet cashed already through the first
four minutes of the game right right
Greg what do you got that's the beauty
of it that's definitely the beauty of it
Bryson I like your second play the UConn
play I like that one a lot we know Miami
tends to to start off slow I like how
they did against Texas uh but
I'm gonna add FAU first to ten just to
see right like our guy producer Ryan
says just to see what happens here it's
in that plus 100 they are the dogs in
this tale they've been under underdogs
all torny
um but they are facing a squad in San
Diego State who also has that Underdog
identity sort of right
um
it's physicality versus speed here right
and and I'm gonna go with the speed when
we're racing to the first 10 points of
the game
any any objections to FAU yeah
no and I this is just this may or may
not be real but fau's One race to 10
every game I swear I refuse to believe
differently it feels like they've won it
it feels like I don't want it if anybody
wants to say I'm wrong please tell me
I'm wrong but I'm like basically
challenging it's fact that they've won
race to ten
all right we got producer Ryan in the
chat
okay I'm seeing some game parlays
everybody's saying that's right first to
ten and he takes on first to ten
all right
Darian 85 that's that's Ryan's boy right
that is Ryan yeah that is that is Ryan's
boy uh f8a if we're filling The Vibes
man let's just lock it in like if if you
guys are feeling good about it you know
I don't know if I'm feeling good about
it I'll be honest but if we got a two to
three vote and we got also darian85 in
the comments riding with us
let's lock it in
yeah all right it's in there I just
great comment from Ryan here if this
hits we all need t-shirts with the
parlay on it I might have to act up and
make another t-shirt for the first to
ten parlay
it's a great call from him all right
let's move on to this next game
moving on to the next game we locked in
FAU first to ten there's
yeah there's no questions we're not even
hearing any Miami
propaganda
I mean if someone has an argument
who am I not to listen but I don't think
there is one does anyone
doesn't yeah look CJ the chat he's
saying FAU person every game it hits I
like I said that's the most factual stat
I've ever made up in my life I actually
think it might be right
um but I'm telling you guys you like how
is Miami scoring 10 points for you guys
you guys winning the tip and they're
going to go down and they're going to
pass the ball in the paint and they're
going to get the first bucket in the
first 15 seconds of the game
two seven Footers
um one of them only plays like 15
minutes a game but
I think fouls are going to be a massive
issue early in this game for Miami I'm
I'm with it I'm in there like swimwear
on Yukon this plays plus 233
how we feeling this is where it is there
it is I think that's it here I already
got it locked in all right we got after
you raised to 10 points first half
that's plus 100 if you want to bet it's
straight parlay that with Yukon first to
ten points first half that's minus 150
all comes out to plus 233 on DraftKings
um
hopefully you're sitting with the last
leg after 10 minutes of this first tip
let's go let's go let's get that early
money all right here we go we're locked
we we got our we locked in our race to
10 parlay but for the people who want to
bet money lines or spreads today let's
look at some money line parlays but
first drop your favorite final four
money line parlay in the chat we might
read it we might ponder it we might even
ride with you uh Logan Logan are you
seeing anything in the chat do you have
any takes
I got I got my eyes on it right now I
see
FAU money line
from Wii Smith 44. FAU money line and
Yukon minus two and a half a little bit
of an ALT line there
um I think we're sticking with money
lines today
uh I don't want to play with that all
the time especially in a final four tilt
um okay I'm seeing some Miami love
quick money is the best money you're
right bowling quick money is the best
money
let's look at the prices let's look at
the prices
look at the money line prices
I mean we got we got FAU at Plus 125.
yeah go ahead and re-read them yeah yeah
so I got I got every parlay combo here
we could click through them this is what
the favorites look like San Diego State
is a minus 145 favorite Yukon is a minus
240 favorite a lot of juice to eat there
but that favorites parlay will get you
to plus 140 right
um and then we have every combo here and
we could talk about it Bryson I know you
had something
yeah but I just want to go back to Wii
Smith 44 in the chat yeah
why on Earth are we taking Yukon minus
two and a half why why in the world
would you buy an ALT line that's still
subtracting coins from your final score
that is the dumbest thing I've read in a
while I just wanted to call that out and
say why would you know how to take the
money line you're you're getting an
extra like 20 cents on the dollar back
taking minus two and a half that was
just ridiculous can't believe that
happened
um what's everyone's actual take here
like does anyone here have a take like I
think Uconn and FAU are going to win is
that what's going to happen probably not
because I can't see the future but
that's just my take that's how I feel
yeah my my take is listen I've been
burned by FAU I mean this is personal
personal reasons here I've been burned
by FAU every single round
um I think the nation was burned by FAU
against our
our Cinderella fairly Dickinson right
um and this this I'm taking a a line
from my good friend Bryson Stricker here
this you want to be on the right side of
History here right
I think we're all owls today
I think we're gonna fly
Fly Away
it's physicality versus speed and I've
already said that and I'm taking speed
every single time
Godspeed manifested yeah and and what
that looks like Greg what do you got man
what are you thinking
well
you know
the Yukon Miami game I'm locked in on
Yukon
but this Florida Atlantic San Diego
State Bryson ah
I just can't call it I cannot call it
one thing I would say though is that
that San Diego State team
they have seven seniors
not one not two not three not four not
five seven seniors in their rotation
that means that they're playing and
usually in these tournament games you
need experience so
and and we know what fau's have done
this tournament so like I'm torn I'm
honestly torn I gotta go call make a
couple phone calls talk to some people
after the show and figure out which way
I'm riding in that game but I'm all over
UConn all over Yukon
all right okay I see it's a good take
this is what a favorites parlay looks
like all right Plus 140.
um
I'm not going to be caught dead one's
falling one of them
that's that's all I'm going to say Greg
and it's nothing personal I hear you I'm
hearing you out
um
this team is great
they're super physical I mean I just I
think they should have lost to Creighton
I think they should have lost to Alabama
good I just don't think this team agrees
is good unfortunately but
um
Bryson so you're also leaning Florida
Atlantic let's see what that looks like
all right we got FAU here I you've gone
down here there's no other option
there's no other option for me than
Florida Atlantic not to cover three
points like that like they don't have to
win the game I would like them to win
the game we got a guy downstairs that's
going to win a lot of money if FAU wins
the game but I assume to cover three
points and I think it's gonna happen I I
think what happens beyond that we got a
couple points to work with both ways I
think that game's gonna really be good
um if Florida Atlantic City shots bro I
just don't I don't see how San Diego
State can keep up with them but if
they're not which is a very realistic
possibility which what happens every
time I bet on teams they forget how to
make layups
um it could be a long day so that'll be
interesting
it can be a long day I hey Logan let's I
mean I think we I think we know what
we're rocking with I think we like FAU
in the first game I'd like to keep
trying to second game Let's lock it in
and let's get let's get to this next
segment
um but go ahead before we lock it in but
yeah read it read it first look right
through it got you guys so we got FAU
plus 125 and that's moving down you see
it on the shirt I got plus 130 here
right I mean I'm not gonna lie I came in
here with my mom made up I'm acting like
I'm here in everyone's opinions I I
wrote it on the t-shirt at 8am this
morning FAU Plus 125.
Yukon minus 240. that gets you a plus
218. at DraftKings
kick your feet up enjoy these tilts
there it is there it is that's too much
you want to see what the dogs say
yeah I'm just curious like is it fat I'm
not fat man I gotta
575. okay that's not bad
that's not bad that's not bad there's no
way y'all that's not bad
I just I just cooked up a four teamer
downstairs that's about 575s pretty
lucky but let's move on to these final
four bets let's move on to these final
four bets let's talk
our best bet for the final four uh
Bryson
do you want to go first
yeah I guess this is top because it's
like it has to be Florida Atlantic but
like I don't like Florida Atlantic to
win the national title right now like I
but I I I'm not betting UConn at minus
110. yeah you're not getting me anywhere
near a window to better future at minus
110. there's no world I'll ever do it
I'm not doing it so it's not Yukon I I
lean fa I just I do think FAU has what
it takes man like what I think is a
little bit different about this team
compared to the and I guess you can call
them a Cinderella but like they've been
good all year guys they have three
losses they really I know everyone says
that but it's like dude they they were
like really hot in like December and
January and said they were you know
getting ranked they're moving up and
they had a couple losses and say oh
they're in a bad conference blah blah
like I think the numbers isn't
Conference USA like wasn't it the best
performing Conference of the tournament
like this team has been playing like
been playing good teams like this team
is good and so I I just think that like
there's a slight bit of value there
where it's like I I don't think San
Diego State is that much better than him
I do think there's a lot of Brothers San
Diego State beats him tonight but
um I I would take with Florida Atlantic
there just because
I don't think they should be that big on
underdogs like I think even the look
ahead line like mine are plus six and a
half against UConn bro I'll take that
like if they keep winning they're gonna
keep covering but whatever happens
happens so I guess we'll see man
G regular what are you thinking
uh it's my turn you guys want me to go
um I can swoop in if you need
no no no I can go I can go right now now
you guys know when I usually go with my
heart what happens
and so uh My Heart Is Telling Me Yukon
and that's being the chalk eating weasel
uh My Heart Is Telling Me Yukon they're
the better team on paper as everybody
probably uh know as you can see that
they're the favorites uh but uh
you know
something else is telling me that
there's a team in Southern California
and I'll just leave it at that make sure
you guys
check out BR betting social to figure
out which way we're riding later but uh
Logan let's go go ahead take it away
um
listen I I we had some Shark Tank
pitches for the future that the BR
betting Community was gonna ride before
the tournament
um I took UConn
at 25 to 1 ish not sure the exact number
there
um and honestly I think minus 125 is
still a pretty good price
um
to to get there I mean they have every
single the they're the team that's built
to do it I mean they have swing men they
have players on the floor that don't
even look to score dedicated to just
getting the rock passing it out to their
Shooters two seven Footers
I mean
it's the perfect storm it's the perfect
storm they they're built to win this
title so I'm on the Yukon Huskies
at minus 125.
it's a raise there it is
quick thing which might in my mind is a
little bit more impressive than whoever
correctly guesses who wins The Natty
right here is I'm very impressed that
when Greg said Team from Southern
California you immediately knew San
Diego State because I'll tell you this
you live in New York which is about as
far away from San Diego as humanly
possible in this country but I'm not
quite sure I knew that San Diego was in
Southern California
and I was in Kansas like I I don't know
why in my head like I kind of thought
they were in the northern part bro I
don't know what
San Diego is the is the closest thing to
the Border bro in California they're
like literally right there
next city over there
but yeah all right good to know we all
right so we all got our we all got our
our our our bets to win it all picks uh
well
yeah me and you we're riding to a Yukon
yeah that's true that's true but I heard
that you might like some other team
that's down south and Cali
yeah yeah yeah yeah they gotta the
people gotta tap in to be our best
socials for that one but uh hey I need a
Vibe check I need I need a Vibe check
from you guys how we feeling today
uh Logan talk about your parlay on your
T-shirt uh let's start off with that
Logan talk about your parlay on your
T-shirt need a little Vibe check and
then Bryson give us a Vibe check and
then we're gonna get up out of here
sounds good
um T-shirt parlay first leg cash we had
Man City money line Bryson was up
watching that at 4 30 a.m to make sure
everything was all good nothing was
going wild
um then we got Elena re bikina some
woman's tennis you know
um Alexa lock minus 250 money line in
the final in the Miami open then we got
FAU I mean we're all at owls today I've
already said it and then we got UConn
moneyline
um the last two legs of this parlay are
the same as our Squad ride parlay so
riding with the community come on man
come on man we connecting dots that's
all we doing is connecting guys Logan
put the put the parlay on your camera up
close and personal uh your ticket so
that people can screenshot it but while
you're doing that Bryson talk to us what
our Vibe check you have your aura shirt
on uh how you feeling
yeah I feel good man I feel like today
is where I get Redemption on this show
for the Oral Roberts situation I think
we're gonna hit our race to 10 parlay
I've already placed it for a lot of
money
um I've got like I've got so many bets
in here man my wallet looks skinny right
now but just know that if things go our
way there's gonna be like three and a
half Grand in here and then we're going
to berries and that is all I need for
the day man Vibes are hot it's been a
good trip so far man
hey Vibes are high I heard we've been
winning already we have been winning
already uh but I'm trying to win some
more y'all I'm trying to win some more
so let's let's let's let's take our
talents down stairs so we can go uh
actually I'll meet you guys at the
counter how about that I'll meet y'all
at the counter downstairs we are a body
here man we about to go win some bets
peace
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]